this is a production of Cornell
University
there's a lot of people in case you came
to the wrong room I'm David wickle this
is my exit seminar and today I'm going
to talk to you about some of the
comparative genomics that I've done in
seed-free Plants over the last few years
so first why study seed free Plants
despite the fact that they're sometimes
easily overlooked in the shadow of
dominant or angiosperm dominated Flora
Seafood plants especially Ferns and
lycophytes are really cool they're
incredibly diverse in form they inhabit
a diverse array of habitats and serve as
important members of the ecosystems
where they're found
as their name implies they don't use
seeds instead they reproduce via spores
which can create these independent
haploid gametophytes that then go on to
release sperm that fertilize eggs
producing sporophytes starting the whole
cycle over again uh they're also
evolutionarily important uh so ferns are
the sister lineage to all seed plants
and lycophytes are sister to all other
vascular plants they've retained lots of
important ancestral traits uh things
like vasculature and sporophyte
branching and have also independently
evolved key features like roots and
leaves and this is really important
right we're making comparisons that can
help give us an idea about the hidden
processes that guide evolution
so I've talked about why seed free
Plants but why genomics the last 10
years have been a real Renaissance for
genomic research there's been a surge in
the number of assemblies published as
you can see over the years on this
y-axis and also in the quality of those
assemblies or sorry x-axis as shown on
the y-axis here uh despite this surge in
genome assemblies right there are a lot
of orders that are still poorly
represented and and that's because
genomics tends to focus on species that
are economically important or that have
small genomes and unfortunately those
kind of plants are in the minority among
Ferns and lycophytes so there are lots
of orders of ferns for which there are
no genome assemblies and as of when I
started this PhD a couple orders of
Leica fights that also did not have any
genomes
so today I'm going to talk to you about
my research and uh comparative genomics
I'm going to start off by talking a
little bit about whole genome
duplication using a couple of our genome
assemblies as case studies uh then I'm
going to talk to you about ice sweetie's
taiwanensis and change gears a little
bit to talk about cam photosynthesis and
the convergent evolution of Pam and this
aquatic lineage
and I'm going to finish up talking about
my latest research looking into the
recurrent formation of aloe polyploids
in the ice sweetie's appalachiana
complex
so let's get started with whole genome
duplication
I'm going to talk just a little bit more
about genomics of seed free plants and
specifically I want to talk about the
difference between heterosporous
lineages versus homosphorus lineages so
briefly heterosporous lineages which
include all seed plants all flowering
plants
um produce two different types of spores
that then go on to produce two different
types of gametophytes one of which
produces sperm and one of which produces
an egg homosphorus lineages on the other
hand produce a single hermaphroditic
medophyte capable of producing both
sperm and egg and this distinction is
important for genomics primarily because
homosporous lineages tend to have much
larger genomes characterized by much
more numerous chromosomes so in the
ferns the vast majority of lineages are
homosporous the one exception being the
order salvini allies the water ferns to
heterosporous within lycophytes the
majority of species are heterosporous
but the earliest diverging lineage
lycopodiales is entirely homosporous
uh so like I was talking about earlier
right hemosphorus plants tend to have
much larger genomes much more
chromosomes an extreme example is shown
over here in ophioglossom reticulatum uh
which has a chromosome count of over
1200 chromosomes if we compare this to a
heterosporous angiosperm the grass panic
and Virginia Autumn which I believe is
actually a tetraploid it only has 36
chromosomes this is an extreme example
but it's a pattern that's borne out
across all vascular plants where we see
that homosporous lineages on average
have three to four times the number of
chromosomes as their related
heterosporous lineages
see
so I'm going to explain a whole genome
duplication briefly right that's what
the section is about
um whole genome duplication is very
common among all vascular plants
particularly Ferns and lycophytes and
essentially it consists of of just the
duplication of all the chromosomes in
inside of a plant uh this is fascinating
to me because I feel like you know I was
taught that Evolution was a sort of
gradual process right where one mutation
Builds on another over enormous periods
of time
but whole genome duplication suddenly
and rapidly changes the entire Genome of
a plant resulting in usually immediate
genetic isolation from its parental
lineages and also in drastic changes to
its phenotype while providing the raw
material for evolution right in the form
of more genes more chromosomal material
but if this were the end of the story
right we would expect to see plant
lineages heterosporous and hemosphorus
characterized by large numbers of
chromosomes by multi-somic inheritance
by by polyploid expression of genes and
we don't see that instead even in
lineages like say arabidopsis with a
known history of whole genome
duplication we see relatively small
genomes with diploid expression and
dysomic inheritance and that's because
of this process of diploidization
uh so diploidization is the process by
which we go from the state right through
the polyploid state and back to
something resembling a diploid and this
happens through chromosomal
rearrangements uh that restore pairing
of chromosomes at meiosis uh and also
through large-scale loss of genes and
chromosomal material uh typically
through illegitimate recombination that
can lead to a variety of outcomes right
that further serves to isolate these
lineages from one another as well as the
ones that gave rise to them
so because of this process of
diploidization it can be difficult to
detect whole genome duplications that
happened far back in time an
evolutionary time so we do that by a few
different methods the first one is KS
and KS functions on the principle that
when a gene is duplicated the two
duplicates are identical as they diverge
we can plot that Divergence along the
x-axis so if we compare many genes right
within a genome what we expect to see if
there's no history of whole genome
duplication is is what we see down here
in the bottom corner in silaginella a
sort of exponential decrease in the
number of genes and that have higher KS
values right this is a result of
fractionation genes being lost over time
as the Divergent sequence
but in the case of a whole genome
duplication we expect to see these Peaks
and those Peaks represent a cohort of
genes that were all duplicated at the
same time and then are diverging at
relatively the same rate so this is the
first evidence that we can use to
identify whole genome duplications the
second
is phylogenetic reconciliation
phylogenetic reconciliation we take many
Gene trees from many species and then we
compare them to a known species tree and
what we look for in those Gene trees are
branches or clades that are duplicated
over and over and over again in multiple
Gene trees represented by this line here
right the percentage of times we see
these nodes duplicated and if we see
nodes that are duplicated far more than
others we can infer that maybe a
duplication happened there and the
important thing about phylogenetic
reconciliation is it doesn't simply tell
us if duplications occurred it can tell
us when they occurred and place them
into this evolutionary context
the final way that we identify ancient
whole genome duplications and arguably
sort of the gold standard is syntony
so with syntony right this operates on
the concept that
when a chromosome is duplicated an
entire chromosome all the genes along
that chromosome start out in the same
order over time through diploidization
those genes can be shuffled around those
genes can be lost but still for millions
or tens of millions of years blocks of
genes that are collinear or synthetic
exist and we can detect those and those
are evidence that at some point in the
past there was a large scale duplication
right of entire chromosomes so these
plots here actually so centinate between
two different species so you can do
Symphony either within a species right
and if you see synthetic blocks you
expect that there was a duplication or
you can compare them between species and
for instance if you see a duplication in
species a but not in species B you would
expect each block in species B here
represented by dots or here represented
by lines to be represented twice in
species a so syntony similar to
phylogenetic reconciliation can give us
an idea of which duplications are shared
between different lineages
all right now that we're all experts in
detecting whole genome duplication I'm
going to talk about the first genome
today and that's that of al-sophilus
spinulosa this assembly was produced in
collaboration with researchers at the
Chinese Academy of Forestry
and I have some assembly stats up there
but that's not what I'm going to talk
about today instead we're going to stick
to wgd
um even in the best of scenarios when
you have all of the possible evidence
available to you uh detecting whole
genome duplications can be relatively
straightforward by figuring out how many
happened and when they occurred is often
not and that's demonstrated by this
phylogeny here where I've plotted uh the
result of four different studies over
the last four years that looked at whole
genome duplication in the sciately or
the tree ferns right the group to which
this Fern belongs
every single one found different
conclusions represented by these circles
on the phylogen so each of these uh is a
whole genome duplication right inferred
by a different study
um I want to draw your attention briefly
to these with the asterisk different
studies use different species in their
sampling and in these two cases they
only included a single species from the
sciatic AC so it's possible had they had
better sampling and included more
species from that group that they would
have inferred a duplication of the same
place that we did by the way ours are on
here in yellow but you'll see them again
later
uh so we did the usual battery of tests
right that I just talked about uh
phylogenetic reconciliation identified
two duplications one before the
Divergence of ciathease another before
the Divergence of the ciaes uh this was
largely recapitulated by KS uh within
the sciatic AC we can see two peaks
represented here in blue and orange
um in the CIA leaves it's a little
harder to see because it's a very old
duplication but we can see a single Peak
more diffuse uh further out from the
y-axis
but
what was really exciting about this
particular analysis uh was the symphony
so as I said earlier right symphony is
is lost as species diploidized and
becomes less and less informative so
generally over scales of millions or
tens of millions of years it becomes
harder and harder to detect
our most recent whole genome duplication
that we identified in this group
happened over a hundred million years
ago and yet despite that we see this
incredible amount of symphony uh with
each one of these lines representing a
synthetic Gene pair and more than that
uh this one's not organized particularly
well to show that but we see an almost
one-to-one relationship between the
various chromosomes here showing that
there's been very little chromosomal
rearrangement since this whole genome
duplication 100 million years ago uh
this is unheard of in vascular plants uh
there are some cases in mosses and also
in fish where intergenomic Symphony that
is between two genomes has been
preserved for 100 million years or 150
million years
um this is the only case I know of in
vascular plants and the only case I know
where this intra genomic Symphony
following a whole genome duplication is
so well preserved
that being said our homosporous Fern
genome assembly was not the only one
that year
um and so while I would like right to
extrapolate my result to all
hemosphorous plants or at least all
hamasporous ferns uh there are two
problems with that and their serotopters
for charity eye and adiant and capilus
veneris both of these ferns have
experienced whole genome duplications
more recently than alsophilus spinulosa
And yet when we look at the symphony
within their genomes we don't see the
same thing at all they're relatively few
Gene pairs preserved these ferns just
came out these assemblies so I don't
have a great explanation for this yet
but suffice to say that the things that
are that are regulating the number of
chromosomes right that are driving up
the number of chromosomes in these
phosphorous ferns are not as simple as
reduced recombination or or less
rearrangement during diploidization
foreign
ferns there are also hemosphorous
lycophytes and we had the opportunity to
collaborate with researchers at jgi and
also the Chinese Academy Of Agricultural
Science uh to do not one but two genome
assemblies uh in this group The Leica
podiac
that you might notice I said two genome
assemblies but since we're all experts
at wgd now you recognize these as
Symphony plots and I have three and
that's because Preparatory asiatica is a
recent aloe polyploid allopetraploid and
our collaborators at the Chinese Academy
Of Agricultural Science were able to
separate those two sub genomes so that
we could perform analyzes on them uh
separately which was very interesting
for our whole genome duplication
analysis but also much more
computationally efficient currency
asiatica has over 100 chromosomes
so again usual battery of tests right
here are KS plots uh we see single peaks
in both of them and then these vertical
lines that weren't in the other ones
just represent the Divergence either
between uh huperzia asiatica and
diphasiastrom conglonautom are two
species here shown in green or each of
them and their closest heterosporous
relative in isoets
uh the problem with ks in this group is
that substitution rates are very slow as
a result if you have multiple whole
genome duplications these KS Peaks can
tend to stack up on one another uh
making it very difficult to discern
whether this peak represents one or
multiple duplications
so to get more insight right we turn to
our phylogenetic reconciliation and what
we find in diphaziastrum is in fact a
single duplication uh but in huperzia
asiatica we find two one prior to the
Divergence of the two subgenomes and
another prior to the Divergence of the
entire genus
but again what was exciting here was not
that we identified whole genome
duplications
um lycopodioac is Rife with whole genome
duplication yet another thing that made
placing them using KS particularly
frustrating uh what was exciting
was the symphony
so we have our phylogeny here right with
whole genome duplications marked on it
um
and here we have intergenomic Symphony
plots so these are not within a single
genome they're between two
the first one shows Symphony between the
two sub genomes are prepared to asiatica
these species have urged 33 million
years ago which is certainly not too
long for centini to be preserved but if
you look at the representation of
symphony between these two so each of
these black dots is not just a gene pair
that's a block of co-linear genes uh you
see that it's almost perfectly preserved
across both of these genomes they're
almost identical in gene order uh which
is incredible after 33 million years
but what's really incredible is when we
compare these two species uh so if
herzia asiatica and dipasiastrum
complanatum are as divergent as two
lycopodioac species can be with our best
guess putting them at about 400 million
years diverged they've both experienced
independent whole genome duplications in
that time and despite that we see large
proportions of the genome represented in
our symphony plot and not only that we
can also identify a two to four
relationship between the chromosomes
that recapitulates our finding from
phylogenetic analysis that we have one
duplication in diphaziastrum for two in
Hubert sciatica Asia or hubercia
asiatica
so if our findings in alsophila were
impressive this is mind-blowing I mean
you know forget about moss forget about
fish uh there there are no other
examples of symphony being preserved
over these kind of time periods uh so
again right it points to this fact that
at least in some homosphorous lineages
the rearrangement of chromosomes
following duplication or even following
speciation is occurring at a very slow
rate
speaking of rates uh before I move on I
briefly want to talk about substitution
rates in these two groups because it's
another thing that unites them so
sciately have previously been shown to
have low substitution rates using
chloroplast data compared to other firms
and our study used nuclear data right
for both of these genomic data and found
that they had lower substitution rates
in the lycopodiace relative to all of
our heterosporous Leica fights
um and then say at thealese relative to
all other Ferns homosporous and
heterosporous
now while I don't think that this is
directly linked that is to say causative
right uh with with our reduced rates of
rearrangement it's another interesting
correlation that we have between these
two groups uh compared to other
heterosporous lineages and even other
Hamas bris lineages of burns
all right on to my favorite plants uh
we're gonna talk about ice Wheaties for
a little while and we're going to shift
gears uh not talk about whole genome
duplication and talk a little bit about
cam photosynthesis instead
are just an incredible group of plants
uh they're very diminutive right easy to
overlook but they're thought to be the
closest living relatives of these giant
tree-like plants that used to dominate
the Carboniferous flora and in fact make
up the majority of the coal that we burn
today
uh despite being again much smaller than
their relatives uh they have a worldwide
distribution they're very diverse they
occupy a wide range of both Aquatic and
terrestrial habitats
um and and they're part of a long
unbranching lineage right that diverged
from all other vascular plants over 350
million years ago
so we sequence is genome this is
actually the first genomic analysis I
did when I got to Cornell uh but I'm
really not going to spend any time
talking about it uh this will come up
again later we did do our whole genome
duplication analysis and while Symphony
was not particularly informative in this
group we did find evidence for one
duplication uh in its history from a
combination of KS and phylogenetic
reconciliation
but what's really neat about ISO
Wheaties uh is that it does Cam
photosynthesis if you've heard about cam
before it has almost certainly been in
the context of dry adapted plants like
this Cactus or this Agave that do it to
conserve water right so essentially uh
in dry adapted plants cam allows them to
close their stomata during the hottest
part of the day to reduce transpiration
of the environment they then open their
stomata at night take up carbon dioxide
uh fix that carbon dioxide and store it
as malate and then it's released during
the day to conduct photosynthesis while
the stomata are closed
ISO eates does Cam photosynthesis when
it's completely submerged so it's
clearly not doing this to conserve water
why is it doing can uh we got some
interesting information on this from my
colleague Jacob suisa who published a
paper uh where they did CO2 starvation
experiments that show that isoetis is
doing ham most likely because of the
limited availability of CO2 in the water
carbon dioxide diffuses through water
very poorly and during the day it's used
up very quickly by algae and other
aquatic plants in the water column so as
an adaptation to this isoedes absorbs as
much CO2 as it can at night through its
roots in fact
and then during the day right it
releases the melee from the vacuole it
liberates the CO2 and fixes that carbon
into sugar
and one of the first things we found
when we compared gene expression and
isoedes to these terrestrial plants uh
not these terrestrial plants but
pineapple calanchoe and sedum uh is that
gene expression both the genes that are
differentially expressed and the manner
in which they're expressed is very
similar almost identical in many cases
and this was interesting if for no other
reason because there's actually been
some pushback in calling this can right
can is an adaptation to dry environments
uh and and so this really shows that at
least from a genetic perspective there's
really no difference between what these
plants are doing and what these plants
are doing
uh there were some differences between
aquatic plants and terrestrial plants
again for the sake of time I'm really
just going to focus on the one that I
think is the coolest
uh so this is Pepsi well this is Pepsi
too but Pepsi is the enzyme that
carboxylates or that does the first
carboxylation reaction uh in the cam
pathway
Pepsi is a pretty diverse Gene family uh
it can be broadly divided into two
groups there's plant type Pepsi and this
is the one that most people talk about
in reference to can so one that's
generally been co-opted for that first
carboxylation step and then there's
bacterial type Pepsi which is a little
bit more obscure uh often lowly
expressed if at all in photosynthetic
tissues so imagine my surprise when uh I
looked at which copy was expressed in
isoedes and first of all found not one
but two copies that were highly
expressed and then found that the most
highly expressed it's actually this
bacterial type Pepsi
so there is one place right where
bacterial type Pepsi is known to be
highly expressed and that's in the
developing seeds of the castor oil plant
and there it's found to form a
heteroctomer with plant type Pepsi and
is found to be much less sensitive to
inhibition by melee which accumulates in
large quantities in these castor oil
seeds as they're developing
there's another place we know of Right
Where melee accumulates in large
quantities and that's in the leaves of
these Pam plants so while I have no
evidence to support this
um I think it's a really exciting story
right and something that certainly
merits following up on uh that it's very
possible that ISO eates that expresses
both of these copies of Pepsi right with
relatively uh similar expression
patterns in the leaves might also do
this as an adaptation to the increased
amount of melee of melee in the leaves
allowing them to fix a little bit more
CO2 at night and be inhibited a little
less
all right on to my last chapter still
ISO eates but we're going to talk a
little bit about the recurrent formation
of allopolyploid lineages and I
sweetie's Appalachian
so while cam is really cool it is not
actually the first thing that attracted
me to ISO eats uh ice Suite is known for
its really high propensity to form
hybrids and also polyploids
um in fact researchers have found if you
put basically any two diploid species of
isotheses together they will form
hybrids the problem is those diploid
hybrids are sterile basically across the
board
um
that being said they can duplicate their
entire genome right whole genome
duplication which restores fertility
allowing them to form these really
prolific populations like these two of
isolated appalachiana polyploid that
we're going to get to know in just a
minute
so this depicts the reticulate
relationships between ice sweetie
zingomania is the hybrid relationships
uh one species one North American
species and a few other species in North
America and as you can see it's it's
wild all of these species in green are
various hybrids and the polyploid
hybrids are represented by shapes uh
with different numbers of sides right
six sides is hexaploid three sides is
triploid Etc uh and this proclivity
right for hybridization and
polypolidization makes this a great
system to study the recurrent formation
of polypoids
uh one last thing before I talk about
ice speed is appalachiana
uh is throughout the study of polyploids
throughout the history of the study of
polyploids various people have referred
to them as dead X
um most recently in 2011 and 2012 a
series of papers came out that
identified a lower diversification rates
and higher rates of Extinction in
polypoids and this also sort of makes
sense based on what we see in ISO eats
right I said that this would come back
later we find evidence for one whole
genome duplication uh in this whole
history of iso eats and mind you we
could have more sampling right if we had
more species we might find more along
other branches
um
but this doesn't really work right with
what we know about the fact that in fact
more than half or around half of the
species in ISO Wheaties are polyploid so
why are there so many polyploids now but
so few relatively few in The
evolutionary records uh and it comes
back to this idea that perhaps
polyploids form all the time right but
don't actually live that long and if
that that's the case it has important
implications not just for evolution uh
but also for conservation many
polyploids are rare uh in fact a lot of
them are even federally listed species
right but if they don't live that long
if they don't uh say you know admix with
other populations if they're relatively
isolated and short-lived maybe that
effort would be better spent on the
diploid species
so to answer this and some other basic
questions sort of about polyploid
speciation in ISO eates I turned this
group I sweetie's Appalachian I picked
it for a couple reasons uh it has a very
large distribution its parentage is
already known uh I've gotten a lot of
mileage out of this poster that Peter
made like I don't know how many years
ago uh but postdoc in our lab Peter
previously found that it's the product
of at least two separate hybridization
events uh between icewear's angle manii
and Ice Wheaties validate
uh This was done though with low copy
nuclear genes I wanted to leverage uh
rad seek next-gen C could sing a whole
genome skimming to take a more in-depth
look uh using more populations at how
frequently these lineages formed uh
whether or not lineages can form uh with
either diploid parent as the maternal
parent
and whether or not we see any evidence
of gene flow uh within these species
so I once again got to do a lot of field
work uh I conduct field work all the way
from upstate New York down to Northern
Georgia on this map tetraploids I
collected are represented by Green
squares uh inglemaniae is represented by
Blue circles and is valida is
represented by yellow circles those are
colors I'll try to stick to for the next
few slides that I think there's at least
one exception
um and finding I sweeties in the field
is sort of like playing where's Waldo in
a sea of Walters so there are like five
or six different plant species and this
little Clump in this Lake one of them is
ISO Wheaties uh feel free to tell me
which one
uh so I collected lots of plants I sent
them off for DD rad seek which basically
consisted of me just weighing plant
material into a plastic tube uh but I
also did genome skimming for which I got
a little bit of wet lab uh some DNA
extraction and Library prep uh for which
I was awarded a graduate fellowship at
the Smithsonian I worked with Liz Zimmer
and did all of this wet lab under the
expert guidance of her Tech Gabe Johnson
and as a wonderful and enjoyable
experience uh great to finally do some
wet lab
before I could do anything with that
data I had some work to do working with
aloe polyploids is difficult because
essentially you're looking at a genome
that contains two Divergent genomes with
different evolutionary histories which
makes things like phylogenetic and
population genetic analysis difficult
so I used a somewhat unorthodox approach
that I adapted from a bum barely at all
paper on soybean uh creating a
pseudo-reference using my diploid rad
seek data I did that by mapping it first
to a reference assembly from I sweetie
single manii I pulled out regions where
both diploid parents mapped and then I
took those mapped reads and created my
pseudo-reference assembly
then I took that pseudo-reference
assembly and mapped my polypoid reads to
and reads that map differentially to one
parent or the other were then retained
her Downstream analysis and treated
basically as separate diploid
populations
the first analysis I did was a principal
components analysis and this was
basically just to make sure that my
phasing approach sort of worked and it
appears to have so we see that the
Appalachian eloci in green and yellow
tend to Cluster uh with their diploid
parent like I would expect them to uh so
following this I also constructed a
phylogeny to look for evidence of
recurrent formation of these lineages uh
and basically you know I'm just doing
this by counting monophyletic claims of
is appalachiana that are separated from
their diploid relatives and looking at
this tree we can easily infer uh four
different formation events that led to
the current distribution of iso eats
appalachiana uh sorry I meant to Mark
these with asterisks or something it's a
little hard to look at I acknowledge
uh surprisingly despite this recurrent
formation of icd's appalachiana in every
single case from our chloroplast tree
right we see that ICD single maniai is
the maternal parent uh and I say this is
surprising because there is evidence
that at least between species of equal
ploidy uh that either parent is equally
likely uh to be the maternal versus
paternal parent uh that being said in
species of differing employee uh
differences in sizes of the sperm means
that polyploid sperm cannot fit through
the archegonial neck cells of the
diploid so in crosses between polyploids
and diploids we basically always see
that the polyploid is the maternal
parent uh while these are both diploids
it's possible that there are differences
right in the anatomy of these
archegonial neck cells or in the size of
their sperm uh similarly another study
found that the formation of these
archegonia can vary widely between
species unfortunately the study did not
include isoedes valida but it did find
that ice angle maniai is particularly
prolific and good at forming these are
begonia so it's possible right that I
specifically Mania just forms a lot more
archegonia than I sweetie's valida so
I'm less likely to sample polyploids
that were formed in the the opposite
direction
another sort of surprising result uh is
that we found no evidence for isolation
by distance and what I mean by this is
that as populations get more
geographically distant we do not tend to
also get more genetically dist
and this is counterintuitive at first uh
because we expect icevds to be very
dispersal limited right it can only
disperse passively through the water or
occasionally uh maybe conduct long
distance dispersal on migrating
waterfowl uh but I I honestly expected
there to be quite a bit of structure
here
um
I have an explanation for this though
and I think it's a relatively simple one
uh I think that for something like ISO
eats that is so dispersal limited one
mile is basically as good as a hundred
it's as likely to disperse to that pond
one County over uh as it is to you know
ride on a goose uh two states over and
as a result we see this pretty flat
distribution uh where we have very
distant populations that are relatively
similar but also populations that are
very close together that are very
distant
all right the last analysis I'm going to
talk about today uh is my admixture
analysis and this is to look for
evidence of gene flow Within These uh
species of iso eates either between the
diploid or sorry within the diploids
within the polyploids or possibly
between them
um so this first plot is called an
admixture plot and without going into
too much detail because I think well not
that low on time
um
we're not going into too much detail
essentially you you assign it a fixed
number of populations in this case nine
uh in this case you arrive at that
number using something called a cross
entropy plot but you can also use like
biologically informative numbers right
if you sampled from 20 populations say
you could try to assign these to 20
ancestral populations
um in this case we went with the one
that was identified by cross entropy
which was nine and
what it does is it tries to assign each
of these individuals between an
ancestral population but can also assign
a single individual to multiple
ancestral populations right which we
might infer as evidence of admixture
either in the past or ongoing
we can see that a nice sweetie single
maniai almost all of these blocks are a
solid color uh there are kind of these
multi-colored tails at the bottoms of
them but those are mostly associated
with missing data as missing data
increases those little Rainbow tails on
the ends of them get longer
um we do see at least one instance from
admixture plots that appears to show
gene flow between these individuals in
DW 86 and 111 and these polyploid
individuals at the end now the issue
with this is that these are diploids and
these are polyploids so I don't expect
this to be evidence of ongoing gene flow
um instead would I interpret this as is
historic gene flow between the diploid
progenitors of those polyploids and
perhaps the diploid ancestors of these
diploids
the other analysis that we use one of
the other analyzes that we used again
I'm not talking about it all today
um are are these reticulate phylogenies
uh made in a program called splits tree
and we make these because well all the
trees I've shown you today have been
these sort of branching bifurcating
trees that's not really how Evolution
works right particularly within species
we expect there to be lots of gene flow
between different populations we expect
these things to be able to reproduce
with one another and as a result those
branches on that neatly bifurcating tree
would have lines drawn between them
right showing evidence of that gene flow
and that's all this is
um so here we do see right these diploid
individuals kind of come out on a branch
and might show some reticulation with
those polyploids but another thing that
we see is these despite not showing any
evidence of admixture in our bar plot
these individuals here which are all
polyploids from central Pennsylvania and
Northern Maryland uh show a high degree
of admixture and I'm pointing that out
because it's also something that we're
going to see on future plots
uh one last thing I want to mention
before I move on uh are these large
blocks of color we see so these large
blocks of color actually comprise
multiple sites that I sampled uh some of
which span multiple watersheds so while
once again this could be evidence of
ongoing ad mixture between these
populations the distances are large
enough uh that I would also argue this
could just be example of recent
dispersal of a single ancestral
population right so this could just
represent multiple dispersal events
um of a single population as opposed to
ongoing gene flow
so this is the same analysis shown for
ice sweetie's valida has even more taxes
so even harder to read but
uh if you just look at the colors
we see a lot more evidence of admixture
it's still very limited right for the
most part this is still a plot dominated
by large single blocks of color
um and and each of these blocks
typically represents a single site or a
single watershed
um but we have a few exceptions uh first
of all we still see these polyploid uh
accessions from central Pennsylvania and
Northern Maryland clustering together uh
again I can't say definitively whether
or not there's admixture going on just
from this data uh but it seems like the
most likely example of of gene flow
between polyploid populations but we do
see one really excellent example of gene
flow uh between two diploid populations
so this involves these samples dw90
these are from
the cheat River in West Virginia
and I sampled six individuals from this
population uh two of them come out in
this large group that again does span
multiple watersheds two of them come out
in this very small group uh with another
site from a river located sorry a creek
located nearby and then two of them show
a mixed ancestry between the two almost
perfectly mixed 50 50. so I would argue
right that this is really good evidence
of of one instance where we see active
admixture and gene flow going on between
two different populations in the cheap
River
all right this is my only big long text
slide in here
um inclusion
uh we see that polyploids form very
frequently right in this group uh
despite that we don't see any evidence
of reciprocal formation
um ice sweeties appears to be severely
limited by dispersal but just based on
those admixture plots right we see that
there is evidence of some kind of
long-range dispersal at least
infrequently
uh despite that capacity for long range
dispersal admixture seems rare we don't
have any really concrete cases where we
can absolutely say right that this is an
example of ongoing admixture between
these populations except for that one
example from my sweetie's valida
so what does this all mean right going
back to what I said earlier about
conservation it seems to support this
idea that despite polyploids forming
very frequently uh we see them being
successful pretty rarely and if that's
true I think that
this right the fact that they form
frequently that these polyploids are
important members of the ecosystems
where they're found suggests a diploid's
first approach by which I don't mean we
should forget about the polyploids I
mean that preserving the processes that
recurrently generate the polyploids is
more important than preserving one
population or another per se
uh and that by conserving those
processes right we increase the chance
that
some polyploid lineages might eventually
be successful
um that if those polyploid lineages
serve an important role in their
community that they'll continue to exist
uh without perhaps wasting resources
focusing on on small or or narrowly
distributed polyploid lineages
with that I have a lot of people to
acknowledge uh first of all my
collaborators both at the Chinese
Academy Of Agricultural Science uh at
Chinese Academy of Forestry at jgi and
the Salk Institute for all of their help
assembling these genomes and with
Downstream analyzes we did everybody at
bti in the Lee lab who's helped out a
lot uh the people at the Smithsonian for
teaching me how to do wet lab uh Jacob
for letting me just drop into his office
basically anytime and ask him ridiculous
questions about bioinformatics
um the other Jacob for letting me ask
him ridiculous questions about ice
sweeties Peter too
uh and there are a lot of other people I
need to thank uh acknowledgments isn't
even a strong enough word so I made
another slide
um I cannot thank Layla enough she's put
up with so much uh she's listened to us
ramble about plant Evolution non-stop
she's put up with me being stressed and
late nights and early mornings and I'm
so grateful and couldn't have done any
of this without her
uh my family I literally would not be
here without them uh they came all the
way here from Kansas to see me give this
presentation also Layla's family who
came all the way from Pennsauken despite
probably understanding very little of
this
very kind of you and all the lovely
people
that you supported me through a pandemic
uh you got me through a dissertation I
couldn't be more grateful uh thank you
so much and I'm happy to take any
questions
hurry excellent
on conservation when it comes to plants
like just doubling their genomes do they
can you tell from the outside very
easily in terms of like if you took a
behaviorist approach in terms of them
fitting into this larger like ecological
niche do the diplines just do the same
stuff
that's a great question and one that I
actually uh had intended to address more
directly with this uh this project kind
of got pushed off and off and off
because of the pandemic
um but absolutely and I think an
important component of this analysis
that I didn't do is is looking at uh the
niches that the polyploids Occupy versus
the diploids uh in other species right
there's evidence that diploids really
are just filling in space left behind uh
sorry polyploids are just filling in
space left behind by the diploids
um but there are also other studies that
show that polypodes are capable of kind
of inhabiting these new environments
right spreading to higher elevations or
higher latitudes uh in which case they
would be important as far as if you can
just you know tell them apart generally
in ISO 80s not really uh in other plants
to varying degrees uh uh right so most
of what I'm talking about here is aloe
polyplitty which also involves
hybridization and those hybrids can be
easier to determine from their polyploid
relatives uh than the other case which
is just duplication uh of a single
genome or Auto
um but yeah I think that's an important
part of this project that I would like
to do eventually uh and and I think
would give us a lot more insight into
the conservation implications of
preserving one or the other and I have
another
go ahead
so many humans like try some of their
disease
um most of the time
plans apparently double their genome
yeah why is that like do they just
suppress the hell out of their genomes
when they do that or uh I mean as to the
difference in animals I'm not sure how
well I can comment um but
uh in Plants I mean there are a lot of
immediate consequences of of polyploidy
in a lot of cases so some of the things
that I mentioned right like a
multi-somic inheritance
um bad pairing of chromosomes at meiosis
can in fact have deleterious uh effects
on some of these polyploid lineages
um gene silencing is a big part of it
again allopolyploids tend to be more
successful so I think that that plant's
ability uh to be so promiscuous and
produce so many hybrids is also helpful
because those aloe polyploids have less
problems with chromosome pairing at
meiosis
um and yeah I think in ferns certainly
uh it's been shown that sort of the
immediate silencing of a lot of genes uh
is very important to polyploids
immediately following that whole genome
duplication great thank you structure
yes fantastic talk really interesting
multi-disciplinary approach
um so in the tree Ferns and the
al-sophilas you know so you found High
Symphony
uh but listen to me in two other
homosphorus ferns yes do you think one
explanation could be the life history
the fact that these are long-lived
definitely I mean and that's and that is
something that we suggest in the paper
so the original study that used
chloroplast data and found those reduced
substitution rates in sciately suggested
that it was linked not only to
generation time but to arborescence per
se
um and there have been other studies in
angiosperms that find the substitution
rate is correlated to things like plant
height I mean not just to the generation
time of these plants so I definitely
think that that life history is at play
certainly in the substitution rates and
again well I don't think there's
necessarily a direct link between them
also possibly uh in the Centennial being
preserved time
yeah not related to that question it got
me thinking about the same thing uh the
old-fashioned idea of adaptive Gene
complexes like why are these genes
hanging together versus not because in a
lot of cases right a hybridization for
example breaks apart adaptive complex so
I'm wondering in these arborists uh
Ferns and what's different about being
sort of quote Woody right being like a
tree versus being a more herbaceous type
firm so uh yeah I mean and it's possible
it has something to do with it I I don't
know enough about the difference in in
gene expression between say the Woody
ferns versus the more herbaceous ones
that being said
um
we did see we did analyze gene
expression uh in Alpha espinolosa and
one of the things that was interesting
is we didn't necessarily
when we saw genes that were located on
two different chromosomes we didn't
necessarily see any kind of bias which I
think is unusual in polypoids I think
typically in polyploids both ancient and
recent you do see a bias very early on
that then sort of persists between genes
that are either along the same
chromosome or originate from the same
genome uh and and we don't see that in
al-sophila which is unusual
yeah it was a question of course we'll
see
100 million years 200 million years
so those calibrations actually are
secondary calibrations uh that we took
from a paper uh by West hesto at all
um and
to be fair most of their calibrations
were much deeper in the tree they had
very few calibrations that were actually
in uh the Leica podiac
um but it's by far the most fossil
calibrations that have been used in like
fight tree uh and and they were able to
calibrate the crown age of Leica fights
um and and also I think the crown age of
like a booty AC just not within that
group very much
um it's definitely debatable uh other
papers have gotten much younger
estimates for that but most of them had
had much lower sampling of Leica fights
um and
weren't really focused on like a fight
diversification per se the nice thing
about the Testo paper is has really good
species sampling and they tried a lot of
different clock approaches uh using a
variety of different phylogenetic
methods uh to kind of try to settle on
that date but I I agree it's
controversial
um that they're quite that old
um let's see if I guess that's right
um physical genomes which is really
awesome
this is a microphone AC you have very
very low bracelet chromosome
rearrangements and then you touch on
substitution rates but I didn't quite
pick up on that is that also low or is
it kind of comparable to like
collagenella comparative genomic uh no
so it's low compared so we did it
compared to all of the heterosporous
lycophytes together we compared
substitution rates and compared to all
of them together it's much lower and
then even when we compare independently
to either solar genella or to isoedes uh
the lycopodiac are considered have
considerably lower substitution rates
though
the same paper uh by Testo at all looked
at substitution rates and it does vary a
fair amount within the Leica podiac
um might have noticed that in that tree
there were a couple branches that were a
lot longer than the others in the
lycopody AC and I I think that's
evidence of the fact there are a couple
of groups within like a podiac that do
seem to have accelerated rates of
substitution relative to the others but
as a whole they seem much lower and it
would be really interesting to look at
the genomes in those plates yeah
forgive me if it was like said and I
instead I thank you also for one what a
wonderful talk
um and congratulations thanks thanks
okay my question I'm sorry it's so basic
but I don't understand the basis for the
hypothesis that a hamasporous uh Fern
would have would be expected to have a
larger uh well yeah would be expected to
have a larger genome than a
heterosperous I just don't understand
but so
I mean as to why they would be expected
to there are a few different theories
um that have to do with things like
intercommetophytic selfing right that
maybe they're keeping a lot more
chromosomes around a lot more
chromosomal material around
um because intermediative hit Excel
thing is going to render a lot of
cytomozygous you're going to end up with
more sort of recessive lethal problems
and maybe just by keeping more
chromosomes around right they're saving
that off
um
but I I think that this is sort of
something that's been Revisited a few
times uh as to why exactly they'll be
doing it but the fact of the matter is
they just have really large chromosomes
I mean everywhere you look across an
phosphorus plants again the their
genomes are three to four times the size
of heterosporous uh I think the Y is a
little more complicated uh and I don't
have a great answer for it
all right that's fine almost done
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu